[Music]
i want to share with you all a recent
excursion of mine exploring pop music
now during the last five or six years or
so i've been exploring different genres
and i've been compiling this list of
different genres that i've been meaning
to cover and honestly pop was not on
this list but what happened was i took
on this game where i was pretty much
forced to do a mini pop study so
basically the job was to record 10 made
up piano intros that were inspired by a
list of popular songs from different
generations and at first i didn't think
much about it but the project turned
into a very interesting subject for me
this was one of the first songs that i
listened to and the things that stood
out to me first was the register
pretty close together very efficiently
voiced as opposed to something wider
also the way it's played it has this
sort of
straightforward quality
uh not just the tempo but pianistically
i feel almost feel like there are these
micro slaps
happening because you really can't play
it too
loose or loosely
it doesn't sound as right i think
also of course the syncopation
if i were to change a few things here or
maybe just take the first few notes
maybe the first
four
i could probably turn it into
[Music]
something like this which is classical
and not pop sounding at all
or
if i were to
[Music]
let me okay
something like that maybe also
i'm using those first four notes
but as soon as you go back down
this progression is
not commonly found in classical music so
[Applause]
anyway
that is one for example
i took all those things and try to
intuitively come up with a distant
cousin version of it which ended up
sounding like this
[Applause]
if i were to spread the hands apart
it doesn't sound as poppy
or
have everything down here
maybe get rid of the syncopations
also less poppy
this is another one that i listen to
of course i said what i did about
the lower register but here of course
it sits perfectly fine in this lower
register i think it's because of the
increased simplicity of
of the pattern
if i were to just keep one direction
it almost sounds like
moonlight
it's also very consistent
it's just going up and down the cord
and i was going for that loosely
speaking in my version which was maybe
less of a
further cousin from this
than the other one was to a thousand
miles
[Music]
all right so you get the point
afterwards i continued to just ponder
about this it became interesting to me
and
it just sparked something in me to
continue to ask the question what
exactly is pop music what makes pop
music pop music the first thing that i
did was actually call my good friend
andrew huang who's helped me with so
many different things because he is a
master at so many different genres and
so many different skill sets so i called
him up and i asked him this very
question you're in a unique position
where
you do so many genres sometimes when i
see your
instagram posts or your youtube videos
you would specifically identify this is
more of my pop side or this is more of
my experimental side so what are you
tapping into when you
say that this is more of a pop side of
me well for me i specify things because
i've just found over time it helps to
contextualize
things for the listener helps to set
expectations
and when you're outputting a lot of
different kinds of things
i just feel like that is a helpful thing
to do rather than people being
completely shocked or something and when
i say pop i think that um i mean it's a
term that means that has meant a lot of
different things over the decades but i
think essentially it's like this idea of
creating a song in such a way that it's
meant to be fun
catchy
singable have a bit more um immediate
appeal
immediately a lot i like that yeah yeah
yeah i think it's it yeah it's about
being accessible i guess okay but that
changes of course over every several
years we have a completely new sound of
pop is there a way to define it as a
genre
musically
i think that um it
tends to have a very similar structure
very kind of like predictable
three choruses
almost everything is based around the
basic kind of verse chorus verse chorus
bridge chorus form even though there may
be variations within that i think
basically from the point where we were
recording singers
probably vocals have been a prominent
feature of like there's very little
instrumental pop music but there's
periods of time where i feel like
some
sounds of pop
you couldn't really define us other
things i don't maybe maybe that's not so
i'm thinking about like the 90s
[Music]
a boy band you know backstreet boys
right
that that just feels like pure pop to me
even though i guess you know there's
maybe they're probably borrowing from
like underground dance music of the time
and certainly the songwriting might have
had a history throughout like
you know somewhat older styles but um
yeah there are certain sounds that feel
like they are just
pop in a way i think well i guess this
is true for many genres you don't
necessarily have to have the whole
checklist of elements to be able to
make it you know to be able to apply the
labels so i think
plenty uh like actually any pop song if
you performed it just on the piano i
feel like still retains just enough of
the
poppiness to it kind of i think
exploring that line
of like where does it become pop that is
usually when i do a genre study like
this i go to my instagram and i ask the
many wonderful individuals that follow
me over there what their favorite song
in a particular genre was and just
cycling through all the answers i found
one that was very piano centric that i
thought was perfect for doing some
further experimentation with it's
somebody you loved by lewis capaldi
and when i was at the piano i decided
that i would take the beginning portion
of the song at least and cycle it
through different genres and different
styles
[Music]
to the best of my ability of course i'm
more familiar with some than i am with
others
[Music]
i just had some fun trying to find that
point where
it becomes more or less pop and to my
surprise this was a lot harder than i
thought it would be because
it was not a matter of just shifting a
few things
first in terms of harmony there are four
chords that are repeated throughout the
song
if this sounds a little familiar i think
it's because it's only one chord away
from being packable's canon
here i just changed the rhythm slightly
while keeping the melody the same
[Music]
and when i changed the chords a bit and
still kept the melody it sounded like it
could have still been a part of the
original
then i changed the chords further and
added the sort of bossanova feel
once i changed certain things about the
melody it was no longer the song
and for certain genres i needed to
change
so much more than just a few tweaks here
and there
for example here where i was trying to
imitate the style of chopin i really had
to change the chord progression quite a
bit and was only able to retain a small
portion of the melody
when i'm doing these genre studies i'm
really driven simply by curiosity as a
listener a player
a music appreciator in general but also
there's a part of me as a composer that
is very interested in trying out
different things yeah even if it doesn't
stick to what i normally do just in
practice try something out experiment
with it and in this case i set out to
write a popish piece not necessarily a
pop song or a fully pop piece
i guess you all will let me know how pop
i got
but i
was paying attention to a few things
first
the bridge chorus bridge chorus
oh no the verse chorus verse chorus
bridge
chorus
form
um yes anyway to me that form is sort of
like going between
two areas like a teeter-totter and then
going to a different space and then
coming back to this teeter-totter i
don't know if that made any sense but to
me that's how i thought of it
also i
really tried to come up with a catchy or
memorable melody
[Music]
that's part one
part two
and i was thinking of the chords that go
underneath it and when i usually do that
i tend to come up with these patterns
that i favor a lot of times when i'm
improvising or writing music here are
the three chords for my piece
that's really detached and chaotic i
don't know i just like that kind of
sound
so this was prior to recording the
actual arrangement i was just playing
around with the chords and this might
have been the default direction that i
would have taken
and as soon as i started doing that it
lost all of its catchiness or
memorable qualities so i i really
changed directions and decided that i
was going to keep it simple
and basically i just kept looping that
chord progression
[Music]
after the bridge and then coming back to
the original with again a few tweaks
i
ended the piece with a sort of fade out
i thought that was appropriate
and
what else yeah i think that's it
here's the piece
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is so familiar and so obvious to me
that i almost feel like
this melody has already been written and
if it if it has been i'm so sorry i
didn't mean to plagiarize or
copy at all
i just this was my best attempt at
looking for something catchy
so if it already exists it's probably
just subconscious regurgitation but
anyway i hope you found this interesting
for me it was especially intriguing as a
composer because
just the practice of
coming up with a melody that is very
distinct like this
i thought was great
a great exercise and
yeah having a melody is
quite cool it's something to think about
something to chew on and other than that
let me know your thoughts in the
comments and i will see you very soon in
the next video bye
[Music]